welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in paulo costa officially weighed in
friday ahead of his ufc 278 clash with
luke rockhold costa who has had issues
making weight in the past tipped the
scales exactly at the mark he needed to
hit 185 and a half pounds after making
weight costs a turn to reporters to send
a message to the us anti-doping agency
who he accused of disturbing his sleep
schedule to draw blood
and a half 185 and a half the official
rate for aloe costa
[Applause]
thank you
went into further detail about the
incident with usada on twitter the boss
on usada who sent their agents this
morning at my sleep room 6am to take my
blood out i was cutting weight very
dehydrated and they once took my blood
those guys i never been caught by usada
test i don't need this
one of the ufc's biggest stars jorge
mosbidal reportedly has his next
opponent lined up number six
welterweight gilbert burns told mma
junkie that maz vidal has verbally
agreed to fight him and the pair are now
just working out a date nothing done yet
a lot of talks about the fight with
mozvidal he verbally agreed i did too
they are just figuring out the date no
date yet november was too close so
december or january at least i know i
have an opponent just figuring out the
date right now ufc 282 is scheduled for
december 10th and will reportedly take
place in las vegas meanwhile ufc 283
will be held in rio de janeiro on
january 21st while burns does want to
fight sooner rather than later the
prospect of fighting in his home country
does intrigue him number one would be
msg in november but then he said no for
that date now december or january i can
wait like 20 more days to go to brazil
i'm looking forward to go to the brazil
card
bellator's michael page and bare knuckle
fighting championships mike perry will
cross over this weekend as the main
event for bkfc 27 in london michael page
spoke with mma junkie ahead of the fight
and expressed that he feels like he has
the mental edge over perry i think it's
a massive show of nerves because he is a
fan of me i've seen that from the first
time i met him because he's known about
me for a very long time he's actually
called me out which i found out recently
he's called me out before he went into
the ufc i've obviously been a highlight
in his career for a long time where i
just heard of him i've seen him more so
from his personality than his actual
fighting and of course i went and
watched his fighting typical tough guy
but great personality here brendan
schaub will be joined by friends bert
crichter and matt mitrione at 11 am
pacific this saturday for the bkfc 27
calabasas fight companion join the gang
right here on thick boy youtube check
out the link in the description to
subscribe for bkfc 27 mvp vs platinum
i'm the one and only mvp michael venom
page
entertaining unusual unique i like to do
stuff that doesn't necessarily make
sense
[Applause]
i think i'm one of the toughest men on
the planet it may not always be pretty
but damn it you can't beat me we'll see
if he ever comes forward at all
i want to go in there i want to land
shots and not be touched up i'm more a
sniper like i said man if he's there at
the end of it well he'll be bleeding
connor the brown town bombing
[Applause]
go
hitman 187.
[Music]
fight companion guests and former ufc
heavyweight matt mitrione shared his
thoughts exclusively to thick boy fight
news on ufc 278's main event between
kamara usman and leon edwards
i think marty's the best the best 170
pounder alive right now so i think that
in any which way you look at it he's the
best welterweight all he does is go out
there he scraps he throws hands he's a
great wrestler he mixes it up i don't
see anybody beating him unless marty
beats himself but i don't see it
happening and i definitely don't see
marty losing to leon edwards
usman and edwards had an interesting
exchange during the pre-fight press
conference about the finer things in
life they can both afford as superstar
fighters when asked if he thinks things
are getting personal with usmen edwards
deferred to accuse kamaru of letting his
ego get too big video courtesy of the
mac life um it's not personal for me all
it is is i believe i am number one and
i'm going out with it
he's clearly getting to his head he's
just about now closing his t-shirt open
wearing a t-shirt and closing the top up
but it's so good like i said listen if
you look like me you would dress like
this too bro
you don't like terry crews bro leon tell
the people what you drive back home what
kind of car you drive i don't look like
you what kind of car you drive you know
what i drive what no wardrobe no what
kind of car you drive tell the people
mercedes journey what are you driving
what what
so it's getting to your head too right
again to my head why
listen listen this is what it is it's
just it's just envy it's just envy
listen you like nice things i like nice
things and like i said if you look like
me you would dress like me too i've
always said fair play to you for trying
trying what you're trying you know but
the fame is definitely getting to your
head and i'm
that wraps up another week of thick boy
fight news head into the weekend with
another rendition of friday funnies
that's your route baby
anything that will work right now
i do feel a little stronger i'm not
gonna lie yeah
see this [ __ ] right here you got
to do your [ __ ] homework
the more grounded i stay the more
dangerous i'm going to become and you
know i can use this platform just to be
a you know put a mask and be an idiot
and
it's not my thing it feels so good to be
myself enjoy this and
that was a crazy fight
that was i'm really excited you know
normally i'm i'm not from chopping the
legs looking for more original mma
content check out the rest of thick boy
youtube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shob show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action
you